how's Gomes man is pure pie we are back
with episode 3 of alien isolation we are
lost at a space station having our
menstruation sorry I got a little
carried away there with words that rhyme
I feel bad Hey look at this keyboard is
amazing what is all this buttons do I
wonder how they designed it soon but I
hate let's put a [ __ ] pink a little
smiley face on there oh I love what they
did with the mattress here this man this
God interesting the emergence the
emerging nan neo psychology of the I
can't read it's too tiny cool so we
unlocked at all they didn't unlock [ __ ]
actually we open up their electricity
and this kind of left over a space
Airport station and laFonda eyes yet to
reveal herself I can't [ __ ] wait for
laFonda to reveal it all but more so I
can't [ __ ] wait for this spokes to
keep at look how many dead people there
are we don't know what happened we just
know that something happened and we're
stuck here too it's kind of cliche but
it works I think we missed something
over here but I'm not sure let's keep
looking
hello what goes Oh God
I keep hearing like sounds and [ __ ] and
it spooks me out man
I don't like another one of these what
do you want from me I don't have a
maintenance Jack C space barrels what
are you doing here
you just had to follow us to space and
yeah oh great he's dead
I can't go in there where do I go then
Oh scheisse plasma torch yeah I just
carried that [ __ ] around I'm really
nothing better to do why not this door
seemed half open I wish we could go in
there I own torch what about here what
did we do exactly did it did it did it
did it it didn't click here to craft
item I didn't construct I load the
Fallen so we constructed a medkit in
case [ __ ] goes down I should kind of
need it should we try it just for fun
mmm we missed something but I don't know
where Rolly up here where I came from
let me check it really quick I don't
know man what'd I miss
Oh in here we're gonna go in here there
we go okay oh yeah this looks more like
it
I'm Abbi yes that's very useful thank
you
Thank You ketchup a wheelchair holding
those for me thank you another one of
those space barrels I'm getting tired of
this [ __ ]
Oh is he holding what I think we need a
hole I like it I like it a lot
let's put on some beeps space beeps but
that's that's how my butthole opens
sorry about that I'll never say that
again oh oh oh see I should have been
beets I would have changed the planet
for good instead of just becoming a
giant douche well a tiny douche actually
that's more like it
oh do you bro see this that does not
look human
I look like space blood to me no wait it
is human this is so dark so he crawled
down here and then he crawled over here
what did you do Stephen what did you do
I need it Stephen Stephen don't fight
make think I need this more than you do
oh god you're disgusting me Stephen
let's see what Stephen had to say my
name is Zachary Watson
that's Watson you hear that oh now we
can remove these
Marshalls they should be protecting us
it's their job what do they do then
[ __ ] nose
he put braces on the doors lockdown
you know like to keep something out it
did work a Braille but you died bro
so Oh God the marshals knew what was
going on and they care more about
protecting himself so they were like
Yolo to the oh did you hear that the
sounds in this game and all right we
need to go in there finally I knew I
missed something
welcome BNV Bienvenue willkommen
Bienvenue to become a very common what
is this oh yeah these are those that
tells us about I don't know how to read
them though remove that what what hap Oh
cutscene I like that uh-oh stay still
okay
turn around oh look it's Captain Picard
come on what are you doing here I'm
Ripley
where'd you come from Ripley off station
spaceship there's no ships here there
are now well that's good news because
things are not so good here
something flew just now rock this whole
place I saw it yeah what was it but lady
that's the least of our problems
yeah he's ballin yeah something's on
this station something you wouldn't
believe
like what akela you get it okay
okay whatever you say what's your name
it's getting hot in here I'm so I was
boarding with two colleagues Evie eh we
got separated by the blast can you help
me find them
why because your balls know your way
around
I mean why what's in it for me Jesus
place on the ship how do I know I can
trust you I need to find coms I need to
contact my ship
doesn't really answer the question does
it smack is phasing this is your lucky
day I wouldn't really call it my lucky
day
Sikhs and combs is in the Cystic spire
it's quite a distance but we can get to
transit through the freight area but
watch yourself we can get an all sorts
of trouble there okay okay Picard
whatever you say but don't call me
sweetheart I kind of freaks me out
come on I don't want to stick around
here long do you believe in magic I just
did this amazing thing and you're just
dusting your heels off yeah gimme that
you following me back there hard to keep
my distance
can't take any chances so it was him oh
well that makes me feel a little better
stay close to you oh Jesus
hey don't move yeah that's right with a
space ASIS I'm John
this is Ringo Ringo fools we haven't got
time for this
come on Janna we're trying to get to
comms can you help us we don't need
their help
don't tell them anything look I've got
the elevator working
Jana let's go okay I I'm sorry
good luck Wow but [ __ ] off then
immigration office what are you gonna do
there huh why should toss us about why
are you so damn aggressive everyone is
running shift scared
peep into their own c4 that way Jesus
sneak up on me what the [ __ ] what is
gonna happen
where's the alien the alien must be the
killer right that he was referring to I
can only imagine the ship of yours is
the real McCoy what do you think what do
you think I am save Shan Shan Hanna
lamination yes please
yeah specialist pulled up let me get the
elevator all right okay whatever you owe
me places all needs a special touch okay
I'm just gonna make sure no one sneaks
up on us all right we care we're good we
get high five captain wait sorry I'm
just gonna sit which button oh okay
sorry thought you could do that you're
welcome
you're very welcome and this can awkward
I'd appreciate it if you told me what
the hell was going on right now listen
uh when we get to this ship we can kick
by read each other's here you don't have
hair oh I need to know what's going on
right [ __ ] now fine like I said
there's a killer a killer what does that
even mean
I ain't seen it but it's here picking us
off one by one is that how you lost your
hair psycho a person know something else
a monster I don't like that a monster I
like how casually he just dropped that
and I don't even care
I'd be like a monster [ __ ] please what
are you talking about there's no
monsters right oh god he looks scared
you look scared captain captain calm
your tits it's gonna be all right I'll
go first
look I found a bonding agent and space
bears I suggest you stay away from them
I've been to in many games in my life
and never can they be trusted some say
they are hid there to watch over me but
there's always danger when they are
around [ __ ] we need to move this way oh
Jesus Jesus [ __ ] man should be looking
for a way off
are you crazy there's no way no [ __ ]
gate push me for how long [ __ ] what
if they come for us
stop it crap out of them you're making
me nervous
stop pushing me captain god damn it
captain trouble we'll have to go random
follow me the space bottle got it
I know you were a spaceball when I
watchin how do I go in there we go
it's a shame on me now friends of yours
Shh those guys before they don't like
strangers even these guys like me I'm
shocked I'm gone you're Jane darling
you want to go and say hello it's your
funeral those guns I'm for sure someone
should be doing something they are it's
called surviving so everyone is that
extra alert yeah makes people crazy I've
noticed it makes people do crazy [ __ ]
well this is cut what is this you've
been living here how can I see my
Butler's on holiday grab what you need
you don't know when you'll get another
chance sensor nice shoe can I have that
it looks like it's my size too okay save
solution should take that flashlight
with it gotta love my shame I stocked up
on batteries Shan Shan tack all right
what do we got bonding agent flashlight
how awesome a sparse flashlight what was
that what was that
it's be careful not to flash it around
you don't want to get cold
let's go but I wanted to check out
around I wanted to read the asteroid
brain and collect your scrap if you
playing patients again it against itself
Lee what a loser
shut up
how do I turn on the flashlight there we
go let's go inside
I don't like this breast I feel like
we're gonna run into a monster soon
there's another vent right here
somewhere
I'm artists or wouldn't forget it toggle
on and on oh god oh god what was that
who made you move what is this I don't I
don't trust anything this it I found it
I'm coming I found it it's right here go
in I'll keep an eye out could be
anywhere see you somewhere see got it
covered
I'll say it is there okay just hurry up
I don't like this just it's too dick
it's too dark
can I go first that'd be great come on
don't tell me to come on I'm [ __ ]
coming on all right you're the [ __ ]
guys slow Jesus all right I'm gonna go
in
ha gotta make sure we're not followed
it's not smart to stay here too long
well I definitely wasn't put either by
toe close to earth implies the way
everyone travels around here just those
that want to stay alive oh well we saw
one who died struggling like this so
it's not exactly so that's your ship huh
yes you it's easily mistaken with
torrents and porn we have the same shoes
like what are the coincidences something
flashlights off Jesus calm down what did
I do
oh yeah I hear you will do gotta go meet
the others something's going down
there's always something going down come
on we don't want to piss him off come on
someone will send help soon someone will
help sumo
so everyone is stranded on this ship I
don't know I feel about this save
station got a lamb I save say shine what
does it say Ruby our early will okay so
we have to wait that's funny
what do we got here ooh some excess crap
I'll take it
thank you sorry sir don't shine a
flashlight you can't tell me what to do
what are you doing talking to the
barrels I think I don't see it quietly
I'm sorry sorry I'm quiet okay why don't
we got Oh God I promise
what's the emergency someone else has
been here marianna cast a alert keep
your guns tight shoot anyone you don't
know wow I mean do many of them take on
take on
yeah but the [ __ ] are you talking about
captain go to get through there the door
at the end that door you're cray-cray my
distraction the generator that window
they'd have to check it out we're
generating here just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
aren't you he just wanted me to do to
John chapter supplies last
I did what I thought us the [ __ ] is that
supposed to mean
this is no good we're supposed to be
secured me duty sealed where is it ready
someone this is the generator alright
boss is it goddamn store clerk yeah
maybe you think you could do better
he's not saying that just say just stop
saying oh and help me check the room
what happened
Oh God do they see me okay Oh God
huh huh go down go down get down to
little Oliver Oliver everyone this is
safe to go out okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay why are you running
away from me so dipp'd barrels still
close by alright that was close save
station gotta save station ah Jesus that
made my heart beat I think I have a
crush on Captain sorry what you want to
go in here we should probably get going
yeah what is this place Oh God it looks
like we'll have to end the episode there
but I hope you bros enjoy watching I'm
really liking this so far I think it's a
great series out I hope you bros are
with me on this
thank you for as always for leaving a
like and a comment on my website that's
where I am that's where you'll find me
that's where we'll hang that's or
life happens but yeah I'll see you in
the next one bros as always thank you
for watching and stay awesome bros haha